warpaint auf der bühne das ist raus
magie sinnlichkeit
eine echte bereicherung in männlich
dominierten rockbusiness klar es gibt
ganz viele tolle männer bands aber diese
herrschaft dauert nun schon zu lange an
da kommt einfach etwas frisches rein
wenn frauen zusammen sind wir
kommunizieren anders und ich glaube
frauen sind heute eher bereit zu sein zu
arbeiten
sie liefern das leuchtende beispiel das
funktionieren kann
jede der vier hat gleichen anzahl am
sound und auftritt ein kollektiv mit
flacher hierarchie
ich sehe uns als demokratie von
diktaturen wir verhandeln eigentlich so
ziemlich alles zusammen
das übernimmt keine die alleinige
führungsrolle was es uns wahrscheinlich
leichter machen würde aber das
verständnis als kollektiv ist genau das
was unserer band ausmachen so bleiben wo
pence überraschend und schlängeln
entlang der linie zwischen
experimentellem psychedelischem sound
und eingängigen popsongs wie den
neuesten clip
warpaint ist das baby einer frauen
freundschaft zwischen den beiden
sängerinnen emily cox und zusammen mit
der bassistin jenny lind burg sie
gründeten die band vor zehn jahren in
los angeles
2009 folgte stella moskau auf drei
männliche schlagzeuger vier
unzertrennliche schwester von dannen
also kriegsbemalung steht auch
verschenken feministischen
sprachgebrauch sich als feministische
band nein überhaupt nicht
wir betonen nicht ständig das wir lauter
frauen wichtig ist dass wir selbst sein
können
die andern sprechen uns anziehen und
miteinander umgehen können wie es uns
passt
also nicht wie oft üblich möglichst
knapp bekleidet sondern wie in diesem
frühen clip im nachthemd durchaus auch
reizend als etwas schrille sirenen
bald waren sie gefeiert als die neuen
königinnen des underground
nun hat das quartett den schritt vom
geheimtipp auf die großen bühnen
geschafft und bleibt dort ein recht
einsames phänomen
zumindest heute noch die zeit ist reif
für frauen rockbands in der
vergangenheit war mehr kampf oder eine
gewisse haltung damit verbunden
in der 90er jahren gab es da die riot
girls bewegung
da ging es um selbstbehauptung von
weiblichkeit um feminismus oder um den
kampf gegen das system
wir stehen an einem punkt wo wir nicht
mehr so viel kämpfen müssen weil diese
frauen das tehran geebnet haben diese
freiheit nutzen die vier und spielen
ihre vielseitigkeit aus von
mehrstimmigen gesang bis zur
überraschenden rhythmus wechseln
so ist unsere art unsere energie
spielerisch war sich sinnlich und mit
viel rhythmus all das macht uns aus
diese vier ladys beherrschen ihr
handwerk
so häufig wie sie derzeit auf der bühne
stehen ist es gut möglich dass wir ihnen
im sommer an einem der grossen schweizer
musik festivals wieder begegnen können